there's one thing the city's taught me
you can put a price on anything
secrets reputations a life and trust if
you have to ask you can't afford it but
then I suppose none of that matters when
you're me after all when did I ever pay
for anything too much light just make it
a little more cozy in here
someone's a bird lover that paintings
more might taste I should take a closer
look
what well they do call the rooftops of
Thieves highway I just hope that's
nothing I think it is
ah
Aaron of course it is care to make a
little more noise next time how else
would you know is me
bakso did tell you we were working
together on this right well I showed up
so what do you think I think you haven't
changed a bit
come on it'll be just like old times
just jump across
glad you could make it did you pick that
root because it was faster because he
thought it'd be fun can it be both come
on let's get Basso his commission
are you going to use any of those
shadows lady lamplight
I was just scouting I know you always
like to go first
you should get yourself one of these see
you on the other side looks like I won't
be going that way
let's finish unloading before summer's
day is over why not drink to a job well
done
first we can't just leave the car down
here it's festival time your average
thief will be under a table in an ale
house and the watch will be liquored up
- I'm not haggling fine for the drunk
god again
Garret come on jealous of the claw I
made it myself
I'm sure the watch will be very
impressed but certainly here is coming
you'll have to catch me first just be
aware of your surroundings it's not
about taking in the sights Garrett's
it's about taking in the loot you do
still steal right I've been stealing
system
look what I found you and me out on the
town why did we stop doing this again do
you really need to ask
and it pays to keep a low profile in
places where I'm not welcome there's a
lot of those places
hard to keep a secret for this
neighborhood
if you're going to urinate in the street
like a watchman at least do it out of
the light everybody can see you I'm just
the middleman
besides you're the only one watching
every day I'm reminded what against you
come on let's go try those cab wings
how much did you steal it's not how much
you steal it's what you steal and how
you steal it looks like this primal
stone thing that basa wants is in the
ceremony room but Northcrest manor
it's the Barons mansion
won't be easy worried yes so should you
be fine I'll pick up your slack this
job's getting more complicated by the
second that's a lot of guards they're
definitely not here for the summer
festival dance a lot of guards means a
lot of Steel thieves and swords do not
get on well I've never had a problem
with swords but then again I'm not just
a thief
we can't let the Barons guest see this
thing giving out and we can't freaking
see without it off and on all the time
so you can't fix it do I look like an
engineer to you none of the staff can
keep up with all his Lordships
experiments not going to be much of a
brighter future of the light Ronson over
here huh
help the new boy will you he's been
trying to light a fire basket for 10
minutes what am i his father go on
before he sets fire to himself
stupid trust damn things stay lit
every time I get it going it fizzles out
again you couldn't set a cloth aflame if
it was doused in oil son I'll show you
how it's done
if you pack it together too close then
the air won't feed the flames I should
know better my family used to be
charcoal burners oh yeah you don't see
much since the factories came
come on what I need to take him down
quickly quietly
what has happened why'd you kill this
guard he was barely older than you
here's the guard garret wrong please
from time you haven't changed have you
what's that supposed to mean it means I
don't kill without thought or good
reason and I don't get paid for it so
basically it's okay when you do it but
not me I see I get it
but you know that guard he's not gonna
wake up later and follow our trail to
cause trouble want any girls wake up I'm
usually long gone
if you're so eager to leave maybe I
should go first
you're holding me back
relying on that clause holding you back
who did that
everybody here
either I heard something or I need more
sleep
bring the frigging belts if you keep
pacing up and down you wear through
those new boots it's my girl sir she's
presenting me to her father he doesn't
know I joined the watch and the thing is
sir he believes that right sach rumor
about us
you're worried I might be you to this
thing I'd share probably I'm worried
you're gonna get us both killed
I can handle myself okay I can move
faster I can climb faster I can you
could kill faster and make mistakes
faster I get it you're not in control
that's why I'm better do it let's just
get the job done I think we'll do it
without this
I'm guessing that's where we're at
the BRABUS tone
rose
robes are always a bad sign brothers
Cornelius Aldus present the keys this
ban northwest brothers of the awakened
we are gathered here to usher this city
into a new age one of progress and
industrial enlightenment let us begin
the channeling of the primal semla
instructor can scare Makana come on
let's go down there this would be fun no
we don't hear jobs over what are you
joking
something's not right it's too dangerous
and you're not ready yes you know I'm
not a kid anymore
I can do this I'm going down there with
her
you not without this unit
Garrett I'm slipping
you'd be the claw